name ways people usually change their
appearance
plastic surgery
not on the board
these are
boomers go ahead
they changed their hair color
dye their hair is the number one answer
[Laughter]
nick
[Music]
get a haircut
haircut is the number two answer
it's so boomery bro this is like the
most booming [ __ ] i've ever seen
hey go to the gym
yeah work
they change their
clothes
okay
make up
[Laughter]
you see that's why the watch family feud
because it's not this motherfucker's
back
in plastic surgery
come back
there's no water
oh man wow
i think that working out is there
because that takes a while you know
that's months oh that's makeup you can
you can throw on that
yeah that's funny
oh you mad man